[Music
] Across
the wiki I'm
going to go to Wow I read such a special material For some reason it must be that I have a lot of confidence when I put it out in a place called Shokugeki, but Rindo-
senpai is still super  Rare in the history of the moon rarely see
rare cars
ANA for a
lifetime,
Ah,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
Don't forgive me, I'll smash you down over here I'll say it all in reverse
[music] I
'll be grateful for your life, use it
It's the strongest meat, stop it in an
instant or punch it out How can I dismantle the woman quickly?  It's a game,
and for all the parts that go to Rokusen-suji,
you've used perfectly efficient knives
.  A vast knowledge of ingredients and a curiosity about unknown flavors
All of these things have made the 2nd ship of Rindo a great success.
Senior Rindo has three faces as a chef specializing in rare ingredients.
I'm a field worker who systematically explores unknown ingredients, and I'm also a brave barbarian who cuts down materials called [music] and belongs to the Wild.
[music]